Art Institute in California the US and
Latin America Sunday at 1:15 a.m.
Eastern here on book TV former president
of the United States and Nobel Peace
Laureate Jimmy Carter on in-depth live
from his home in Plains Georgia Sunday
December 3rd beginning at noon Eastern
President Carter is also the author of
more than 20 books such as our
endangered values keeping faith and the
blood of Abraham his latest Palestine
peace not apartheid is due for release
later this month join our live
three-hour discussion from Plains
Georgia as booked TVs in depth welcomes
President Jimmy Carter Sunday December
3rd at noon eastern on c-span - now an
author panel on religion featuring
misquoting Jesus author Bart Ehrman
losing Moses on the freeway author Chris
Hedges and moderated by New York Times
national religion correspondent Laurie
Goodstein this event from the 2006 great
read in the park in New York City is
around 40 minutes sorry for our time it
took for us to organize ourselves were a
big big family here a big panel my name
is Laurie Goodstein I'm the national
religion correspondent at the New York
Times and I'm glad to welcome you here
today this is a panel on religion in the
Quran it is written that Muslims Jews
and Christians are people of the book
and that's about right judging by the
amount of publishing going on in the
field of religion as a reporter on the
religion meet I received at least five
new books or galleys each day and I've
seen a dramatic change over the years
with of course 9/11 as the dividing line
before 9/11 I got a lot of self-help
titles books on angels on charting your
chakras what I call self centered
religion
since then a lot of religion books are
more likely to grapple with global
weighty issues and questions like can
Islam Christianity and Judaism coexist
or will World War 3 start next year in
Jerusalem are there other Gospels that
were left out of the Bible and if so why
do the Ten Commandments have any bearing
on how people actually live their lives
today we're going to hear from the
authors of four titles that have risen
to the top of the stacks
they represent the breadth and diversity
of offerings in the religion field today
I'll introduce each book and its authors
before they speak to you we're going to
do this in three segments and they're
going to be very brief because I know
you're going to have a lot of questions
so we're going to start with the authors
of the faith Club Suzanne Oliver Rania
Italy B and Priscilla Warner they're
collaborators on the book the faith Club
which is what you would get if you took
the TV show the view and had Rosie
O'Donnell and Barbara Walters talk only
about religion after 9/11 these three
idealists set out to write a feel-good
children's book about the similarities
of their faith Islam Judaism and
Christianity but they soon realized that
before they could affirm their
similarities they had to confront their
differences their arguments about the
crucifixion about God the Holocaust
Israel and Palestine they're all in the
book no-holds-barred Susana Oliver the
Christian member of the group were up in
Kansas City Missouri where she made her
first communion at st. Elizabeth's
Catholic Church well she majored in
English literature in German at Texas
Christian University in Fort Worth she's
worked at financial world magazine at
Forbes as a senior editor and smart
money comm where she was managing editor
Rania it Lobby is a Muslim American
whose family was uprooted from Tiberias
a Palestinian town by the
see of Galilei during the creation of
Israel she grew up with a foot in the
East in Dubai and a foot in the West in
McLean Virginia she graduated from
Georgetown University's School of
Foreign Service and has a master's
degree from the London School of
Economics love and marriage brought her
to New York City where she lives with
her husband and two children
Priscilla Warner the faith club's Jewish
member were up in Rhode Island where she
received something of an interfaith
education by attending a Hebrew day
school and moving on to a Quaker High
School she graduated from the University
of Pennsylvania with a degree in fine
arts and spent 15 years and as an
advertising art director at various ad
agencies in Boston and New York inspired
by her two sons she began writing and
illustrating children's books she lives
with her family in Westchester County
New York so I introduce you to the
members of the faith Club thank you for
being here as you know by now I am the
Muslim mother I came to the faith Club
out of a deep sense of isolation and
alienation from the public dominant
voice of Islam after 9/11 as the mother
I was deeply concerned and worried about
what it would mean for my american-born
children to grow up both American and
Muslim I knew I needed them to be proud
with that challenge in mind I sort of
hit the books and start reading and it
doesn't take me long to discover what I
feel is the true inner beauty of Islam
the fact that Muslims kneel down and
pare five times a day and end their
prayers the salutations of peace to
Abraham and this and his descendants
including Moses and Jesus and the
Prophet Muhammad the fact that Muslims
believe in the Gospels and the Torah the
fact that Muslims believe that
essentially Judaism Christianity Islam
are but three forms of one religion at
the root the religion of Abraham with
that in mind I'm excited and inspired to
reach out to a Christian mother and a
Jewish mother to try and do something to
write a children's book that would serve
to highlight the commonalities of our
our face
addition no sooner had we started
talking though that of course the the
Jewish and the Christian mother started
having their own conflict which I let
them talk about but I'll leave you with
this thought if they were hashing it
between the two of them I kept thinking
they kept talking about the salient
points in the judeo-christian tradition
and I kept thinking why isn't it the
judo Christian Muslim tradition so when
they finally get to me and the dialogue
the dialogue centers on sooo stereotypes
the first one is of course the idea that
Priscilla came home soon from a cocktail
party and she said you know you say your
God is our God - but I don't know very
erudite man said to me their Micah vs.
Medina versus and so and so forth the
idea that within Islam within its text
at the text hold holds the root - to
conflict to a religion of a sword spread
by the sword I'm here to tell you that
nowhere in the Quran does it say kill
them you shall be rewarded and that when
religion is used to justify violence or
as a tactic of war it is no longer a
religion but a human ideology and has
nothing to do with God's values the
second stereotype is the idea of Islam
being repressive and anti women and I'm
here also again to counter that image to
tell you that 1.6 billion Muslims in the
world choose to stay within the faith
tradition of Islam not because it's a it
came to suppress and discriminated
against was against women but rather the
Prophet is revered as someone who came
to advocate as a champion of women's
rights to personal things had to happen
I came to the relay to the face club
someone describing herself a face but no
religion and through our dialogue I had
an affirmation I come out and more
confident and affirmed Muslim the two
big challenges for me was I needed my
faith tradition is my religion to
sustain my belief in a universal God the
good news is it does there are many
verses within the Quran that confirms
the idea that had God willed he would
have made us all the same tribe creed or
religion but it was by God's intended
design that he would have us of
different religions because he wanted us
to know one another and through
actions prove ourselves the second issue
is the idea that I would have to dress a
certain way wear a veil perhaps or live
a certain way each a certain way to
drink a certain way in order to qualify
as a Muslim I was helped with that
challenge through essentially my finding
an imam whose wonderful and he was able
to refine for me the difference between
religion and face when he shared with me
an anecdote about the Prophet Muhammad
when he was asked what does it take to
be a good Muslim well the first thing is
a belief in God the second the
prophecies the third is to act as if God
was with you once you have fulfilled
these three requirements you have faith
and then and only then should you choose
to you can use your rituals of your face
tradition to service your face so the
faith up is basically a dialogue of the
common person it's a call for us to have
this dialogue we're here we're honored
to be amongst these wonderful scholars
theologians and people who are so
accomplished we are mothers who set out
to have a dialogue with our children in
mind and we found it so liberating and
our call is that for you to go ahead and
do the same and for me personally as a
fellow American citizen to ask you to
ask me the tough questions please don't
live under the misconceptions and
assumptions don't add me as the other
and for Muslims it's a call to to read
the Quran to make it as part of your
fabric of your life because as Muslims I
feel like we can celebrate the universal
God accessible to all we have access to
the Christian God the God of passion and
love the Jewish God the mitzvahs and
actions and third the the Muslim God God
accessible to all I'm very excited
because I feel that in the very near I
know I'm going to pick today I have I've
been asked to summarize 60 minute
presentations three I'm getting down to
my punchline
so this is it I'm looking I I look at my
daughter and my son's not here but my
daughter's here and I'm very confident
and secure that I know that in the near
future they'll be able to speak of the
and proudly speak of the great American
judo Christian Muslim tradition
I'm a Jewish mother I came to this my
crisis of faith was purely about fear
after September 11th I was basically
paralyzed terrified of terrorism I Rana
CLE had gone to a Hebrew day school I
was very well grounded in my religion
but I say I had religion but no faith I
answered a phone call from Suzanne
Oliver it seen the whole world was
screaming about religion and I thought
well if I meet these two women and I
said Tana we talk calmly about religion
maybe something will come of it
little did I know we would not be
talking so calmly and quietly people say
we took off the gloves people say we
said things nobody says to each other we
built up a level of trust over a number
of years and I do think that it's a
conversation that many many people can
replicate but the most important thing
that I learned was the first tenant of
the faith club was honesty if everyone
wants to be validated for who they are a
very important lesson for me I came into
it with some stereotypes when I walked
into Ronnie's apartment I'd never met a
Muslim woman before I'd certainly never
met a Palestinian woman before and later
I wrote that I expected I was shocked
that Ronnie would sit down and talk to
me face to face so honestly welcome he
so graciously into her home I grew up
you know with this notion that Jews were
gonna be pushed into the ocean and
instead she fed me fed me beautifully
and fed me body mind soul all across the
board I had some stereotypes about
Christians oddly enough even though I
went to a Quaker school and had as I say
some of my best friends were Christians
but I met a woman a lot of the they I
think the strength of this book is that
we were all strangers to each other
Ronnie ensues a met at a bus stop
Susanne made a phone call and got hooked
up with me so I met a woman who went to
all Catholic schools grew up in the
Midwest Texas Christian University who
loved Jesus and spoke about Jesus very
openly and Jesus was kind of a stranger
to me al I talked a lot in the book
about how Jesus is a stranger to the
Jews and when we got into our discussion
about the crucifixion you have to read
the book because I've only got three
minutes and that's a good way to plug
the book but we got into very animated
discussion about Jesus and after
and over the course of many many months
read to me from the Sermon on the Mount
and some of my very favorite quotes of
quotes in the book come from Jesus I'm
proud to say that I'm now in a
first-name basis with Jesus I talk about
Jesus to my children and I read in the
chapter after you can imagine the
conversations we had after the
conversations that divided us we had
amazing conversations about what United
us as Rania says we all begin the same
way and we will all end the same way we
have all lost loved ones we've all
suffered pain one of the important
things I learned in the book my
conversations with Rania and Suzanne was
not to quantify suffering not to compare
my suffering to anyone else's it doesn't
really serve to move people forward
everyone has pain everyone suffers but
after the painful chapters came my
favorite chapters and I in the end of
the book started off as a person without
a definition of God by the end of the
book after flying over the Great Lakes
and looking down below me and
recognizing my humility which is Suzanne
Rania pointed out to me Islam means to
submit and that means to acknowledge
your humility in the universe I Shrunk
myself down and paradoxically I found
enormous power in that and my definition
of God is the one now that begins my
book in its Martin boobers definition
when two people relate to each other
authentically and humanely God is
electricity that surges between them and
I say that when we were together sparks
fly and the current is very strong I
[Applause]
might tell you a little more about what
some of those sparks were um I am
obviously the Christian I came to the
faith club project after 9/11 when like
many New Yorkers and many Americans I
was interested in learning more about
the Middle East and Islam in order to
assess how safe my family and I were in
New York and what was going on so I met
Rania at the school bus stop our
daughters started kindergarten together
that year and when she started telling
me the story she had come across about
the connections among Judaism Islam and
Christianity and told me her idea of
writing a children's book I jumped at
the opportunity to spread a message of
peace among three religions whose
differences were really fueling violence
and misunderstanding and hatred
I'm in fact she'd already invited
another Christian and I grabbed the
phone and told her to cancel that other
Christian right away because I wanted to
join this project yes if I was going to
summarize my faith club journey very
quickly I would talk about it as one of
being from a certain amount of certainty
to doubt as I started the faith Club I
was very interested in learning more
about Islam and Judaism
I thought of Islam is a violent religion
controlled by men and filled with
mistreated women yet he was Rania who
wasn't covered who didn't seem to be
mistreated by her husband whom I met and
who drank a glass of wine and on
occasion I wanted to know how she
reconciled what her modern life with
what I thought of as the religion of
Islam and my knowledge of Judaism that
we showed the Old Testament was not that
much more substantial I thought of it as
an ancient and exclusive religion and
one that didn't benefit from Jesus's
message of love and life everlasting so
while I was interested in learning more
it was in a more of an academic sort of
way I didn't think that what I learned
was going to sway any inner conviction
or suspicion that I had that
Christianity was the superior religion
of these three but then as soon as we
started talking everything that I
thought came into question and I started
to question language that I'd been using
for 40 years
you know how old I am and not really not
really thinking about what that language
meant too early on as Rania is talking
about her temple in church Envy because
she doesn't have a mosque in New York
where she feels very comfortable I
brought her to my Episcopal Church and
thought maybe it could be a sort of a
spiritual foster home for her a place
where she could join in our charitable
projects and we had all celebrated this
one-god that we believed in so her
family came with us to Easter service
and the music the flowers is all
wonderful and then all of a sudden we
started talking about Lamb of God and
body and blood and the sacrificial lamb
and I started feeling really
self-conscious and wondered what is this
all mean that I've been saying all the
time and realizing that this was
actually something that separated us so
then there were other things that were
coming to the forefront right away as
Rania started talking about Muhammad's
mission on earth I felt Jesus's position
threatened by a follow-up prophet that
we'll hadn't God
his trump card with Jesus why would he
need to send somebody else and as I was
talking about the crucifixion with
Priscilla and she heard words
differently than I had meant for them to
be heard and thought that I was accusing
Jews of being Christ killers
she asked me at one point as I was
writing about Pentecost if I could just
leave the crucifixion out of the story
so it shows you how far we've come about
things like that now I suppose as we
talked about Priscilla was talking to me
about Reform Judaism Zhai dia of a God
existing without an afterlife that
really made me question my own idea of
God because God an afterlife had always
come hand-in-hand as we came to talk
about Jesus as a symbol of love and
suffering and I started questioning
whether he was divine did I have to
believe he was divine as he was a
Christian as I started reading books
like misquoting Jesus I started all
these questions came forward I was very
lucky to have access to a fantastic
priests at my parish who reassured me
right away with the words the opposite
of faith is not doubt it's certainty and
from that point on I was really able to
embrace my doubt it kept me humble it
allowed me to open my mind I was able to
see how Priscilla and Rania both found
elements in their own tradition that fed
their spirituality that brought them
closer to God and I quickly will summon
up then I brought him Priscilla and
Rania with me to st. James my church and
we were talking to the teenagers about
our own journeys as we were having our
conversations together and I think one
of them asked us well in order to
believe in your own religion don't you
have to believe that the other two are
wrong and I think this was the Nugget of
what I was wrestling with through a lot
of the faith Club and I told them that
no I didn't think so that I didn't think
God differentiated between a good Muslim
with a Jew a good Christian a good
atheist and that if God didn't
differentiate then why should I and I
was able to find certainly lots of
quotes within the Bible that I felt
supported that and as we have gotten
emails critical of the sort of
universalistic view that I've come to
even though
scripture that they put forward I am the
way the truth and the life the only way
to God is through me is one that I see
is being so open because to me that says
the only way is by following Jesus
message of love and compassion for your
fellow man and that I know is common to
all three of our religions thank you and
thank you for keeping it tight we I want
to I want to give you enough time to get
to know these writers but also to have a
little bit of time at the end to ask
questions so our next our next speakers
are both going to speak on a similar
topic earlier this year the National
Geographic Society upset a whole lot of
people with the announcement of a new
archaeological discovery the Gospel of
Judas it turned the Bible's version of
Judas on its head and among the experts
whom the National Geographic Society
called on to help interpret the texts
for the public were these two writers
I'll start with Bart Ehrman who's at the
end there he is the author of the Lost
Gospel he is a distinguished professor
at the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill he chairs the Department of
Religious Studies there and his
specialty is the New Testament and the
history of early Christianity
now bark has his own interesting
personal history of Christianity I'd say
in his youth he was a conservative
evangelical and he attended Wheaton
College in Illinois later at Princeton
seminary he began to question whether
the Bible is the literal inerrant Word
of God his own search for answers is
reflected in his scholarly books he's
written and edited 19 books and among
his most recent are lost scriptures
books that did not make it into the New
Testament and misquoting Jesus the story
behind who changed the Bible and why
I'll also introduce Herbert Krasny he's
the author of also the lost gospel the
quest for the gospel of judas iscariot
he's a writer and documentary filmmaker
he specializes in investigative and his
Oracle projects and has worked for the
BBC PBS The History Channel and the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation he's a
graduate of Harvard he reported for the
Alba new times Union newspaper and then
served in the US Army and then he moved
into television working for CBS ABC and
the predecessor of PBS national
educational television and how many
people remember that in 1968 he went to
Israel the head the documentary
department of Israel television and in
1970 he formed his own documentary
company he's produced pieces on
Jerusalem World War two Russia and
Iran's nuclear ambitions in addition to
the lost gospel Crosby has written
several other books including beyond
welfare poverty in the super city and
deadly business legal deals and outlaw
weapons so I give you Bart Ehrman and
ferb Grozny thank you in some sense
Christianity has always been in a state
of crisis because Christianity from the
very foundations of the faith has
insisted that Christ in some sense is
the way of salvation and yet Christians
haven't been able to agree on what that
way entails the Gospel of Judas that's
just been discovered and published just
six years ago six months ago now by
National Geographic is a good
illustration of how diverse early
Christianity was but Christianity today
continues to be extremely diverse if you
compare what a Greek Orthodox priest
thinks with what an Appalachian snake
handler thanks or an Episcopalian with a
Mormon or Jehovah's Witness with a
seventh-day Adventist you have an
enormous range of beliefs and practices
among Christians today in in the ancient
world the beliefs and practices were
even more diverse my my expertise in
Christianity is in the 1st 2nd and 3rd
centuries in the 2nd and 3rd centuries
there were Christians who obviously
believed that there was one God there
were other Christians who believed that
there were two gods and some said there
were twelve gods we know if some
Christians have said there were 36 gods
we have one Christian group that said
there were 365 gods
which is very convenient because then
you could have a God a day you are God
for today Christians believe some
Christians believe Jesus was both human
and divine some said he was human but
not divine some said he was divine but
not human
Christian some Christian said God
created this world others said God never
had anything to do with this world
different Christians had different
points of view and they all claim that
their points of view represented the
views of Jesus himself as as found in
the writings of his apostles all of
these various groups had books that
claim to be written by apostles that
represented each of these mutually
exclusive points of view the Gospel of
Judas is one of these books that now has
been discovered that has that
illustrates quite well the diversity of
early Christianity the Gospel of Judas
is a product of early Christian
Gnosticism Gnosticism is a is a term
that scholars use for a range of
religions that understood that the way
of salvation is not by faith in Christ's
death and resurrection but by the secret
knowledge that Jesus conveyed Gnostics
understood that they were alienated from
this world because they didn't really
belong here this material world wasn't
created by the one true God this
material world is a cosmic mistake
created by lower divinities and the key
to salvation is to escape the material
trappings of this world the Gnostics
were people who felt completely
alienated in this existence they felt
like they don't really belong here this
world doesn't make sense to them I felt
this way since the last election
the world the world just makes sense to
other people well they belong here but
some of us don't well how do we get out
of here well we need to get the
knowledge necessary for salvation and
escape this world the Gospel of Judas
conveys this secret knowledge it's a
complicated book in some ways because
the knowledge that it gives the
revelation that it conveys is secretive
and mystical and hard to understand but
those who are in the inside that
Gnostics are the ones who can understand
what this truth is this this gospel was
condemned as a heresy in the second
century and was eliminated from
consideration from the Canon of the New
Testament luckily though a copy of it
was made in in Egypt in the early 4th
century or the late 3rd century it got
buried in a tomb and luckily it turned
up in 1978 the the story of how it was
discovered and and how it was handled by
antiquities dealers until finally we got
a translation of it six months ago is
summarized for me in my book on Judas
but really the the entire story is told
at great length in her prize news book
on the lost gospel working with Bart was
a pleasure because in addition to
anything else he wrote the introduction
to my book and I and and he was a great
great scholar of early Christianity we
really didn't know much about the 2nd or
3rd century almost everything that we
know about the 2nd and 3rd century which
is the formative periods when the church
developed come from the people who were
representing the church particularly
Eusebius who lived in Caesarea in what
is modern-day Israel the one of the
things that has fascinated me in terms
of the early history of the Gospel of
Judas is and and impressed me was the
closeness in the 1st 2nd and 3rd
centuries of Judaism and Christian
and how the Gentile people's in essence
adopting the Old Testament were really
adopting a history which was foreign to
them and which had to be sold to them in
many ways and a lot of this was
represented and and brought to fruition
in the city of Alexandria which three
centuries before in the third century
when it was founded by Alexander the
Great
actually gave a charter to the Jews
saying you will be treated equal to the
Macedonians and it's a little known
history but actually Alexander is a
revered figure in Jewish history and
Gnosticism in many ways there were too
severe repressions of Jews in Alexandria
and Gnosticism is believed partly to
have developed out of that and a lot of
what you see in the Gospel of Judas is a
reaction a criticism of the weather was
the fall of the temple there there is a
reaction against the god of the Old
Testament in other words there was good
news for the Jews and the Gospel of
Judas and freeing up who the Jews were
and the responsibility for the
crucifixion of Christ but also it was a
severe rejection of the god of the Old
Testament and and in fact the Gospel of
Judas is a highly polytheistic document
nonetheless as we come into the present
day we've had extremely interesting
reaction the Vatican people there's been
some journalists who have written that
the Vatican has been extremely critical
of us of novel Gospel of Judas in fact
the goodly Vatican has not commented in
any official way and over the last
fifteen centuries or so on what is
believed to be apocryphal literature but
I found myself on a number of television
programs not arguing with Catholic
priests but finding that certain
Catholic priests were were
reestablishing the early Christian wars
that Bart right so able to
and fighting against the Gnosticism
which they thought that they had
defeated as a dissident movement within
Christianity between the 2nd and 5th
centuries then the negative reaction the
we've had extremely a great interest in
the entire project among all the
Catholic and Orthodox countries meaning
Russian Orthodox and Greek Orthodox we
have had certain letter-writing
campaigns by certain evangelicals
against the Gospel of Judas as if we
were responsible somehow for this
historical document which came out of
the desert
what did what I think I've brought away
from it as the the the sense of
reverence that many people have the need
the need for a defining deity and the
closeness nonetheless with all with all
these conflicts no no that's the
closeness among men of wanting to find
answers to their condition Chris Hedges
is the author of losing Moses on the
freeway the book is an indictment of how
far Americans have fallen from following
the Ten Commandments the books 10
chapters reconsider the commandments
through Chris's reflections and
vignettes of people's lives very
inventive vignettes Chris's best-selling
first book is war as a force that gives
us meaning it was drawn from his
experiences recording on Wars in Central
America in Africa and Yugoslavia it was
a finalist for the National Book Critics
Circle Award he's also written what
every person should know about war Chris
grew up the son of a circuit writing
minister in a small town in upstate New
York he and his father talked Bible and
morality at
Sunday while driving the churches where
his father was to preach he graduated
from Colgate University and then Harvard
Divinity School but he eventually
decided not to father follow his father
into ministry instead he pursued a
higher calling journalism he worked for
the Dallas Morning News the Christian
Science Monitor and National Public
Radio he joined the New York Times in
1990 and was a member of the team that
won the 2002 Pulitzer Prize for
explanatory reporting for coverage of
global terrorism
he lives in Princeton New Jersey and has
a new book coming out in January
not at all controversial the title is
American fascism the rise of the
Christian Right thanks I just wanted to
comment briefly I mean as somebody who
did grow up in the church and then spent
almost 20 years abroad seven of those
years in the Middle East in Israel and
the Muslim world eight Richard niebuhr
the theologian had a great line that you
know religion is a good thing for good
people and a bad thing for bad people
there are passages for instance in the
Gospel of John that are verily
anti-semitic in the letters of Paul
you know denouncing homosexuality you
know there are moments in the Hebrew
Bible when God can be a bigoted cruel
tyrant that seems to bless acts of
genocide if one looks for instance when
Moses leaves Egypt and and I think that
and of course the book of Revelation or
the book of Daniel which are used
extensively by the religious right in
our own country to justify and yearn I
think many ways feed a yearning for
apocalyptic violence and these passages
have to be dealt with because they are
within the Canon the Quran also has very
virulent passage not in the early part
but in the later part against Jews and
how do we deal with these I think in in
some ways we have to accept that those
darker elements and those people that
perhaps a Twitter neighbor would define
as bad people can find scriptural
sanctification for their hatred and
bigotry and I think sometimes we who
who reach out and embrace a more whole
or humanistic approach can ignore those
passages in the Bible just as
assiduously as I think the Christian
right will ignore the Sermon on the
Mount how do we cope with that how do we
deal with that I think as we're entering
an age where the there are powerful
forces fundamentalist forces not both
Jewish Islamic and Christian and of
course even Hindu that get scriptural
sanctification for bloodlust violence
there has to begin or I think a more
concerted response on those of us who
believe in in the religious tradition
but I think embrace the values of the
Enlightenment and a kind of humanism to
denounce these passages within our own
scripture to denounce the book of
Revelation for instance I I think too
often we skirt that issue by pretending
that it's not there and I think we're
reaching a point even with in American
society where we have to confront the
fact that you know even in a Unitarian
Universalist Church pew in Boston there
are within the Canon passages that that
fuel movements that I think are not only
anti religious but anti human thank you
[Applause]
panelists out of respect for you really
and respect for each other have really
been very disciplined in their
presentations and that's to give you
time to ask questions so I open it up to
questions from the audience
understand no I simply shade that is
possibly perversion of religion but I'm
afraid that it's marker in us
actually okay should I repeat the
question yes okay okay he is asking and
I'm not sure which panelist you're
asking maybe you throw it open to the
whole panel okay if we really understand
what are the causes of religious
violence well let me just begin as
somebody who's who'd covered so-called
religious wars in the Middle East or New
Clothes Slavia which I think
fundamentally are not religious wars
there they are wars born out of
collapsed societies and despair and I
really agree with Freud that people will
find ideological structures whether
they're religious you know I think one
could look generically a communism or
fascism as in generic terms a kind of
religion you know I think they share in
common many elements including that
urinal yearning for apocalyptic violence
that believe that violence can cleanse
the world purge the world make the world
a better place and then of course in
this weird kind of spiritual Darwinism
all the believers will be lifted up
their clothes left behind with the rest
of us who will rot and burn and and so I
think that that that and I think Freud
wrote about this very well I think that
what we're dealing with is is those dark
currents that what Freud would call the
love of Thanatos or the death instinct
which is really what these so-called
religious systems are about it's about a
yearning for death I think it's
something within human nature and I
think it's wrong if there wasn't you
know canonical passages in you know in
the book of Revelation or the Book of
Daniel to justify it they would find
something else I I think it's false to
blame religion anybody else want to
respond to that that's it's a very good
request for something rania I think very
well but again I I don't believe the
source is religion and I feel that I
should probably say something because
Islam suffer
from that it's a stereotype that somehow
within its text it's some more prone to
this type of violent reaction I think
that yes we are seeing a manifestation
of this weather but it's a minority and
I think it's more a problem of the
condition of the state channels of
opposition we have it Islam is a
religion in in countries for the most
part that we do not have opposition
confirmed pathways and and and and
education and and civic society and and
I think that's really where the root of
the problem is rather than looking at it
I mean few people would think that one
should just look at the Bible to really
understand the Inquisition or the
Crusades and sometimes in our readings
here of how do we understand this
violent reaction we tend to so be so
tunnel visioned and just to look at the
Quran which I don't think is is the one
problem
guilty of that after all our fish West
in 1842 eighteen fifties under was under
the
came as the justification to do pepper
we wanted the interest of doing God's
will
essentially and we make twice Native
Americans especially
we use the justification for Mexico
comment okay comment on his comment
which is isn't the United States guilty
of something similar with using manifest
destiny okay anybody want to respond to
it
yes it's very easy to to kill another or
two to justify violence or education of
people so and so forth when you make
them other you demonize the whole entire
people culture population that's where
what we have to watch for
[Music]
and last operational terms mistake
I ran this time
which statement legend has
for starters
he's asking about the separation of
church and state he's saying in the
Bible there is a passage that can be
understood as the foundation for the
separation of church and state and is
there anything in Islam which which does
that and he's asking that of Rania very
much belief in separation of church and
state I think that there's nothing
inherently within Islam that would
require otherwise Indonesia is the
biggest Muslim state and it is a secular
state what else can I say I do not
believe that you know this could most
the studies that I've got a student was
very much under the impression that
somehow Islam was an exception it was
different but you know I from a common
person point of view or I sort of feel
like well Judaism has a lot to say about
how you carry a person life to how you
consummate a marriage or you maintain a
kitchen the Catholic Church has a lot to
say about birth control so I feel that
these are all issues that can pretty
much be handled nothing that's
particularly is Muslim that would
otherwise RIF prevent us from separating
church and state
well there's the concept of Sharia in
Islam and it is a belief at least among
certain Muslims or the small radical
Wang if you want to call it small that
does believe in I unify and imposition
of Islamic law over entire societies and
they are fighting for that and you know
I'm not I'm not even being judgemental
but it's just absolute fact that that
that is one of the tenants of certain
elements within Islam well you know John
Calvin believed the same thing I mean
you can find it in you know Christianity
as well so Islam's hardly exclusive yeah
in fact Chris I mean Christianity
historically is not advocated the
separation of church and state the I
mean as soon as the Roman Emperor
converted to Christianity nobody wanted
there to be a separation of church and
state so it's really it's a post
enlightenment phenomenon that this whole
idea that has nothing to do really with
with having any religious hymn impetus
okay one last question yes
like they don't want my violence and how
come there's so much racism I'm like no
everyone's always fighting about alleged
okay all right good question a good way
to wrap up our panel he said so many
religions preach about peace so why is
there so much racism and why is there so
much violence within religion or within
I think in the world this is what you're
asking why is the world the way it is
please please believe me start people
need to start talking when you talk
about peace and religion Rania Suzanne
and Rania came with me to a Yom Kippur
service at my synagogue Yom Kippur is
the holiest day of the year for Jews Day
of Atonement and when we fast and we
pray for an